[Musique]
bienvenue dans pôle it mag l'émission
politique berthet france comme tous les
week-ends on débat avec nos
contributeurs des grands sujets de
l'actualité politique de la semaine et
aujourd'hui nous sommes avec patrick
mennucci ancien député ps et conseiller
municipal de marseille face à vous
florian philippot conseiller régional du
grand est et président des patriotes ont
soit invitée sur ce plateau également
françois poulet mathis spécialiste de
l'union européenne et françois
asselineau président de l'upm
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
sur rt france et c'est à la une cette
semaine regarder il est presque minuit
devant le parlement britannique
la grande bretagne ne fait plus partie
de l'union européenne après 47 ans de
vie commune
après trois ans et demi de négociations
oui à out nous sommes dehors trois mots
qui entérine le référendum du 23 juin
quand 52% des britanniques avaient voté
pour la sortie de lugny enfin oui c'est
exactement ça enfin le pays s'étant fait
réunies a soutenu le break cité a dit
non nous avons voté la démocratie a
gagné donc ça me plumes ont noté à
personne et je pense que c'est très
important pour beaucoup de gens présents
ici ce soir un accord de divorce ratifié
à londres promulguée par la reine puisse
signer à bruxelles cette semaine l'union
jack a été retiré des instances
européennes les députés britanniques ont
fait leurs adieux au parlement toujours
unis ce n'est qu'un au revoir donc il
chantait
[Musique]
oh
et le premier ministre boris johnson a
promis un nouvel âge d'or à son peuple
la chose la plus importante à dire ce
soir c'est que ce n'est pas la fin mais
le début dans ce moment où l'aube se
couche et où le rideau se lève sur un
nouvel acte de notre grande histoire
nationale
et oui cela passe en partie par
l'utilisation de ces nouveaux pouvoirs
cette souveraineté regagné qui va
permettre d'offrir aux gens les
changements pour lesquels ils ont voté
qu'il s'agisse de contrôler
l'immigration de créer des zones
franches de libérer notre industrie de
la pêche de conclure des accords de
libre échange ou simplement bâtir des
lois et des règles qui profite aux gens
de ce pays
bien sûr que je pense que c'est la chose
la plus juste la plus saine et la plus
démocratique à faire parce que pour
toutes ses forces et toutes ses qualités
admirable
l'union européenne a évolué pendant plus
de 50 ans dans une direction qui
désormais ne correspond plus à notre
pays et c'est ce jugement que vous le
peuple avait confirmé dans vos scrutin
le vote non pas une mais deux fois
[Musique]
il est grand temps d'utiliser ces outils
pour libérer le plein potentiel de ce
merveilleux pays et de rendre la vie
meilleure à tous ceux qui vivent aux
quatre coins du royaume uni
[Musique]
et voilà pour le discours du premier
ministre britannique boris johnson juste
avant la sortie de la grande-bretagne de
l'union européenne françois poulet
mathis ce n'est pas la fin mais un
commencement a dit boris johnson mais un
grand saut dans le vide tout de même
selon vous ah oui tu es bon c'était un
grand saut dans le vide mais il ya quand
même quelques jours de très positif
qu'il faut souligner on a souvent
reproché à l'union européenne d'être peu
démocratique
et c'est vrai que l'épisode de 2005 sur
référendum sur la constitution n'est pas
tout à fait exemplaire pour l'attitude
démocratique de l'europe là pour une
fois un vote a eu lieu contre l'avis de
la plupart des dirigeants européens
contre la vie ce vote ait lieu il est
respecté donc il faut se il faut se
réjouir de sa première victoire
la deuxième chose est ce que réellement
les britanniques ont récupéré le
contrôle de leurs affaires ou vont le
récupérer est-ce qu'ils vont le
récupérer je ne le suis pas si sûr c'est
la question tout d'abord tout d'abord
cette année qui va s'écouler
jusqu'au 31 décembre 2020 et ne va rien
se passer
non seulement les britanniques n'auront
pas le gros troll ils auront perdu
c'est à dire qu'ils l'appliquent ont une
politique européenne pendant un an pour
laquelle ils ne participeront pas
directement de bastia parlementaires
sont partis voilà et les membres du
conseil
la deuxième chose qui est importante à
souligner c'est que une fois qu'un
accord aura été signé entre l'union
européenne et la grande bretagne
quelle sera cet accord soit c'est un
accord qui permet à la grande bretagne
du reste est assez proche des
réglementations des des disciplines de
l'union européenne pour pouvoir en
particulier bénéficié de l'accès au
marché unique
c'est une possibilité dans ce cas là on
pourrait considérer qu effectivement ils
ne récupéreront pas complètement le
contrôle qu'ils avaient espéré
c'est à dire soit il n'y a pas d'accord
et à ce moment là ils sont tributaires
effectivement d'un grand talent d'un
saut dans l'inconnu
et pour ça sans aucune garantie réelle
aujourd'hui à et à négocier
de leur côté effectivement florian
philippot ce sont des belles promesses
qu'on l'entende de la part de boris
johnson et
le retour à la souveraineté c'est ce que
vous défendez également passé
factuellement vrai serre que à partir du
moment où vous n'êtes plus dans un
d'origine organisation supranationale
qui vous prive de votre souveraineté
dans un nombre assez considérable de
secteur il en a cité quelques-uns aussi
bien dans les secteurs économiques que
les secteurs régaliens
c'est factuellement vrai vous avez
maintenant la liberté de choisir ce ne
sera pas devenir le paradis sur terre
c'est simplement que ils auront la
liberté de choisir et n'ont plus
l'obligation de subir ce qui est quand
même une différence absolument
fondamental donc moi je suis je je me
réjouis vraiment ce qu'il s'est passé
là-bas d'abord pour les britanniques
et puis je pense que ça va faire avancer
le débat dans les autres pays européens
notamment en france parce qu'on aura un
exemple pour la première fois on aura un
exemple concret et on démontre pour la
première fois également que ce phénomène
européen n'est pas irréversible
il n'est pas éternel comme on nous a
fait croire depuis des décennies c'est
réversible
on peut en sortir et en plus je suis
absolument persuadé que les britanniques
très rapidement auront des performances
en tous domaines absolument supérieurs à
ceux à celle de la de l'union européenne
et en particulier de la zone euro sans
parler des chiffres qui sont d'ailleurs
meilleures que celles de la zone euro je
voudrais qu'on écoute le président
emmanuel macron sa réaction justement à
la sortie de la grande-bretagne de
l'union européenne
un jour triste at-il dit regardez c'est
un jour triste ne nous le cachons pas
mais c'est un jour aussi qui doit nous
conduire à procéder différemment à bâtir
avec plus de détermination encore une
union européenne puissante efficace et
qui parviennent à vous convaincre
davantage et à retrouver le fil de cette
histoire qui fait de l'union européenne
une aventure unique est à mes yeux
irremplaçable vive l'amitié entre
royaume uni et la france vive l'europe
vive la république et vive la france
il faut retrouver une europe qui
parviennent à vous convaincre of patrick
mennucci et en fait c'est un aveu
finalement que l'europe a perdu de sa
crédibilité est ce que finalement le
royaume uni va pouvoir servir de modèle
crois que c'est une costa qui est
évident si on veut que l'exemple de la
grande bretagne se limite à grande
bretagne et de ne pas donner raison à
ceux qui souhaitent le démantèlement de
l'europe pour des raisons je pense que
ça va obliger l'europe à revoir certains
dispositifs c'est moi je pense qu'à
partir du moment où on a choisi de faire
l'europe des nations
on a abandonné le fédéralisme on a fait
une en a fait un élargissement qui bien
trop important et donc on est obligé de
fonctionner avec cette ce système là
après lourd très administratif qui a
fait perdre au fond un peu le sens de la
beauté de ce que disait emmanuel mâcon
de la beauté d'avoir des gens qui sont
comme matures depuis des centaines
d'années qu'ils sont ensemble et qui
travaille donc je je crois que la
tristesse qui l'exprimé moi j'apporte à
jocelyne je crois que c'est pas c'est
pas un jour heureux je sais que monsieur
asselineau et monsieur philippe au ont
fêté ça qu'ils ont fait des fêtes qui ce
sommet pour leur rappeler qu'ils ne sont
pas nés ils sont français et que pour
l'instant c'est cette vie cette victoire
qu'il s'attribue pascaline seul attribut
eux strictement rien fait pour y arriver
cette victoire qu'il s'attribue elle va
peut-être démontrer justement que les
difficultés n'ont rien de factuel
m'attribue rien du tout en tout cas on
vous annonce que vous a vu très content
je vais je me réjouis que mon prochaine
soit comme ça il n'y a pas pour le sujet
si vous voulez vous soyez contre vous
tomberez voilà on vous a vue extrêmement
heureux c'est mon préféré que vous soyez
euros pour autre chose va faire nos amis
parce que moi je
d'abord je me dis que j'aime beaucoup la
la grande bretagne et que j'aime
beaucoup les uns les anglais j'espère
d'ailleurs qu'on va les battre demain
j'espère comme lé bacon stade de france
mais je crois que c'est un recul et là
on a affaire à des déclarations d'hommes
politiques qui en définitive en
défendant ce qu'il défend défend le
libéralisme le plus éhonté le plus le
plus libéral et donc on va voir
notamment florian philippot que
j'entends souvent parfois je bien qu on
soit de bord très différents je trouve
que ce qu'il dit a du sens quand aidées
par l'état qu'un petit défaut moment là
on va avoir vous allez voir libéralisme
montagne il en train de mesures ainsi
qu'au strict et hôpitaux c'est parce que
les conservateurs ont détruit on détruit
le système de santé américain
un jour triste comment avez vous vécu
d'abord très de façon très joyeuse j'ai
organisé j'ai organisé une grande
réunion à paris hier où monsieur
philippe la gentillesse de venir mais il
n'était pas le seul il y avait également
monsieur dupont et niort
il y avait également un monsieur jean le
plus de poissons jean frédéric poisson
du parti chrétien démocrate y avait
monsieur kuzmanovic qui a quitté la
france insoumise y avait pierre lévy qui
est un ancien communiste
il y avait un sujet de casanova qui a
été à auprès de monsieur chevènement il
y avait monsieur dominique jamet
il y avait beaucoup de monde et ce qui
est en train d'apparaître c'est en fait
un nouveau monde et le nouveau monde
c'est pas mon de macron le nouveau monde
maintenant c'est l'opposition qui lie à
entre ceux qui veulent récupérer la
souveraineté nationale la souveraineté
des peuples et ceux qui sont d'accord
pour la destruction d'états nations qui
ont mis l'an 1500 ans d'âge dans une
espèce de magma dont on ne connaît ni
d'ailleurs ni l'objectif ni les
frontières finales mais une chose est
sûre c'est qu'il s'agit de détruire
notamment la destruction de l'unité
nationale
moi ce qui me fait assez ri et c'est
monsieur poulet mathis dissous dans
l'inconnu pince il ya 193 états dans le
monde
il y en a cent soixante-cinq qui ne sont
pas dans l'union européenne
attendez qu'ils ne sont pas vendus en
effet oui mais qui négocie et qui ont
négocié d'accord avec toi mais il y en a
assez peu qu'ils ont 47 % de leurs
exportations qui vont en avignon
ne prétendez pas sans fin dans l'ue ne
prétendait pas prendre aux britanniques
à faire du commerce
voilà et ce sont des gens extrêmement
vague maïs ici deuxième mais ne la
négocie à deux partout pas dans tous les
sens quand même un quart d'heure oui
vous pas de tristesse et de 2 et de joie
mais je vois je vous ai vu que nous est
montré on voit une foule en liesse
extraordinaire à londres des centaines
de milliers de personnes qui exulte le
matin c'est une espèce de 2,10 des goûts
du jour de la victoire on voit une foule
en liesse et puis on veut après que ce
maquereau qui a une tête d'enterrement
c'est lui qui est triste les
britanniques y sont très très content je
vous assure
et d'ailleurs je trouve extraordinaire
attendez je trouve extraordinaire que
monsieur macron nous explique que
maintenant il va falloir faire une
europe autrement mais mcquaid est
complètement isolé en europe sur par
exemple la prochaine intégration de la
macédoine du nord et de l'albanie
macron est complètement isolé sur la
sphère d'une défense européenne distante
des états unis macro est complètement
isolé ces macro enquêtrice parce qu'ils
rêvent à quelque chose qui n'existe pas
voir françois plus réactif vous gérez
j'ai à dire ce que vous dites sur la
liesse générale qui existe depuis hier
en grande bretagne je suis pas tout à
fait de cet avis derrière soir je tiens
j'avais la grande bretagne n'a été aussi
est divisée
les familles sont divisées les opinions
sont divisés est ce que vous vous
rappelez quand même que 70% de la
jeunesse britannique c'est à dire entre
18 et 24 ans ne voulait pas quitter
l'union européenne que la grande
majorité des femmes ne voulaient pas
quitter nos maisons a return temps c'est
la loi de la majorité fait mais c'est
comme si vous disiez le 10 mai 81 par
exemple a vu les français il y avait des
français très triste mais lorsque
mitterrand était élu
eh bien il ya on peut dire qu'il y avait
beaucoup de français qui était
extrêmement ténu de boiry saint jacques
majorité absolue françois poule et
matisse était un deuxième vote en
quelque sorte pour le brésil puisqu'il
en a fait sa promesse bien sûr
vous parlez de des législatives de
settat compte et ça personne ne conteste
cette élection personne ne conteste le
choix des britanniques mais ne dit pas
que tous les britanniques sont ravis
mais ne donne pas mais ne dit pas non
plus que ça françois asselineau serait
triste nous avons il ya beaucoup de
français qui seraient trop il ya
beaucoup de français qui sont heureux
hier il y avait vous allez il y avait
beaucoup de centaines de personnes vous
avez eu beaucoup de gens en france des
filets pour s indigner de la sortie du
royaume uni de l'union européenne pas du
tout dans ce n'est pas que nous deux
arrêtez de faire croire que nous serions
2 il y a aussi regardé la france a
soumis ce monsieur monsieur mélenchon a
fait un message twitter dans lequel il
dit voilà ce que c'est que d'être
indépendants ils peuvent re nationaliser
une compagnie de chemins de fer privés
ce qui fait d'ailleurs qui montrent
qu'au sein de la france un soir là
savent plus où ils en sont c'est pareil
d'ailleurs au sein du front national je
regrette d'ailleurs plus
d'interventionnisme maintenant que j'ai
perdu de la part de l'état pour sauver
des entreprises notamment voilà ce qu'on
peut plus faibles à cause de leur mais
il faut connaître un petit peu les
règles européennes
effectivement ils seront plus soumis à
la politique de la concurrence libre et
non faussée ils seront plus soumis à la
politique de libéralisation des services
publics ils seront plus soumis à ces
politiques du pacte bus militaire déjà
plus libéralisés des services mais ils
sont en train de re section de
libéralisation et c'est eux hier c'était
lé nom vous est amusant parce que je
vous signale que la france de l'union
européenne là ça fait dix ans que le
smic est collé au plancher allow johnson
a annoncé une hausse de 6 3% du smic le
1er avril au royaume uni tout le pays
dépasse pour la première fois qu'il va
dépasser le smic française quand même là
on tient bon les chiffres
si vous me répondre à un point vous dit
le pays est divisé
monsieur johnson a eu la plus forte
majorité parlementaire depuis l'après
guerre
alors comment vous pouvez oser dire que
le pays est divisé alors qu'elle n'a
jamais eu un raz-de-marée électoral
aussi phénoménale que celui dont il a
bénéficié avec une forte participation
électorale aux législatives en décembre
dernier un furet géant bleu a envie d'en
sortir le plus rapidement possible parce
que ce feuilleton avait assez oreca
effectivement ils ont voté pour
confirmer leur voice voilà alors moi je
pense puisque parle effectivement de la
france insoumises du rassemblement
national qui sont eux
alors si on est gentil on dit sont pas
claires sur le sujet moi je
qu'ils sont assez claires en fait ils
veulent plus du tout sortir de l'union
européenne et il le réaffirme
régulièrement mais je crois qu'au delà
de ces partis qui à mon avis ils vont
s'en mordre les doigts parce qu'ils ont
abandonné cette idée au mauvais moment
au moment que ça va devenir justement
extrêmement moderne est attendu par nos
compatriotes
les français vont regarder ce qui se
passe au royaume uni ce qui ne pouvait
pas faire avant puisque effectivement ça
traînait trois ans et demi c'est
épouvantable là ça va avoir lieu on va
voir concrètement il ya l'apocalypse il
n'ya pas l'apocalypse oreilles quand
même on nous annonce et allemands deux
fois l'apocalypse moi j'ai jamais
monsieur aphatie le qui disait en 2016
ils sont un peu crétin c'est britannique
monsieur duhamel qui avaient parié alain
duhamel vous savez les 10 tours est
invoquée par tous en 2000 qu'il est
partout depuis 60 ans 2010cette les pas
concerné par les déclarations de guy
gionet lors du hamel disait on fera le
pari dans douze ans le break site sera
extrêmement impopulaire au royaume-uni
bon ben il a perdu son parti qui bordera
faut qu'il se casse qui nous offre à une
bouteille de champagne bon c'est ce sont
des gens qui se trompent constamment
sont constamment sur les ans alors les
mêmes qui ont fait les prévisions de la
pokal ils sont en train de nous dire
j'entendais ce matin je ne sais plus qui
monsieur bourlanges qui disait je parie
que d'ici 25 ans le royaume uni va
réintégrer l'union européenne
moi je fais le pari dans 25 à plus d'
union européenne bon les mêmes qui nous
disent de l'ecosse va prendre son
indépendance
mais ça ça fait quatre ans qu'ils nous
disent ça dans les sondages et a jamais
eu aussi peu d'écossé pour demander
l'indépendance
donc on arrête de chars fait sur les
peurs ou que si l'union européenne qui
empêchera les gosses de ponchos
independence
mais les commerçants mais ça c'est le
chantage au pays
ils agitent leurs erreurs mais si
j'avais le voulait il y aurait les mêmes
qu'au d'avoir un débat sera intelligent
argumenté sur on reste où on sort qui a
pu que chaque en option le reste le
blabla sur une réforme de l'intérieur ça
c'est du blabla un faisable on reste on
sort c'est le seul débat au lieu d'avoir
un débat argumenté les européistes les
euros gaga les héros fanatiques nous
disent il faut avoir peur il faut il
faut initier sur les peurs savait pas
bien on ne traite pas le débat
démocratique par là peut on à surfer sur
les peurs effectivement j'aimerais qu'on
regarde les chiffres maintenant pour en
parler de façon sereine la croissance en
grande-bretagne selon les prévisions du
fmi en 2000
dix-neuf plus 1,3 comparé à l'europe 1,1
plus 1,4 en 2020 comparé à l'europe qui
est à 1,3 un chômage à 3,8 pour cent
c'est le taux de chômage le plus faible
depuis 45 ans un taux d'emploi de ce
sont les chiffres d'un sondage avant
mais quelle est la définition de l'homme
paul da mota
mais c'est beaucoup il faut être
beaucoup plus il faut beaucoup il faut
travailler beaucoup plus en grande
bretagne pour prétendre au chômage je
croyais les chômeurs et les chômeurs
britanniques
il vous dit ils vous diront pas merci
parce qu'ils savent comme un comité
touche avant tout cas non mais si vous
voulez tout des structures et où
s'harmonisent et maintenant laissez donc
ça dépend laissez moi finir les salaires
ont augmenté de 3 2% et le salaire
minimum vous l'avez dit on va augmenter
au 1er avril 2005 donc les indicateurs
sont pas si catastrophiques que ça
avance a d'emblée matrix contrairement à
ce qu'on avait pu nous annonçait il faut
il faut être franc c'est de l'intérêt de
personne que le que le bris site ne
marche pas tout le monde a intérêt à ce
que le break site fonctionne ni l'union
européenne dans les nids la grande
bretagne n'a intérêt à jouer la
politique du pire
parce que ça va leur tomber en bourse ça
c'est la première chose qui la deuxième
chose c'est que que des sens un peu
boris johnson avec qui j'ai travaillé à
bruxelles c'est quelqu'un qui n'avait
pas d'idée préconçue mais ne savait pas
dans quel sens ils allaient voter avant
devrait faire un ace qui savent donc sa
marque et bien aujourd'hui ce qui est
quelqu'un qui vient du parti
conservateur mais qui a compris qu'il y
avait eu une bascule dans l'opinion
britannique et en particulier tout le
centre de l'angleterre ouvriers les 1000
travail et qui travaillait qui était
travailliste qui votaient pour le parti
travailliste a basculé parce que le
chômage la situation ne marchait plus
donc il a compris qu'il fallait qu'il
récupère un petit peu cet électorat d'où
cette petite carte sociale soutient pas
socialisme et sociale de son monsieur
bob berridge assad est essentiellement
quelqu'un qui est un libéral
ça veut dire que c'est quelqu'un qui est
prêt demain à s'ouvrir avec des amas un
véritable marché avec les états unis
dans lequel la grande bretagne ne sera
pas un peu
sur une force parce que ça il faut le
dire la grande bretagne est un petit
pays qui va se trouver face demain aux
états unis qui en fera ce qu'il voulait
alors il y aura peut-être un accord
aussi négocié avec les yeux on va parler
dans la deuxième partie
françois sinon je crois qu'il faudrait
quand même prendre plus de hauteur de
vue ces considérations souvenons nous
attendait pour ce sont assez médiocres
franchement le grand grand événement
c'est qu'il était écrit depuis le traité
de rome qu'il s'agissait d'une union
sans cesse plus étroite et nos
compatriotes étaient convaincus qu'il
n'y avait pas d'autres possibilités
d'avenir pour la france que de fusionner
dans une europe
non non non non c'est allé beaucoup plus
que ça une espèce de verrous mental
comme la construction du socialisme qui
comme l'a dit florian philippot tout à
l'heure et est censé être irréversibles
et leur immense événement historique qui
vient de se passer c'est que c'est faux
et que les britanniques viennent de
montrer que c'est faux et à partir de ce
moment là vous pourrez dire la plaque
chic au logis de monsieur untel petites
mains le traiter avec les états unis
c'est de peu d'importance da véritable
importance c'est que nous sommes entrés
dans un processus de nécrose de ce jour
de 7h la construction européenne et de
maintenant vous et à l'autodestruction
vous parlerez ce que ça va durer pendant
six mois deux ans ou est-ce que ça va
prendre 15 ou 20 ans n'en sais rien vous
avez c'est comme un château de cartes
avec 28 cartes branlante
c'est comme la construction du
socialisme quand une carte commence à
glisser tout va s'effondrer comme ayant
suivi d'histoire de des institutions
européennes et cette histoire européenne
depuis une quarantaine d'années je peux
vous dire que ce type de discours on le
tient depuis 40 ans et rien ne se passe
mais s'ils sortent jamais affiner ses
sorties et ça va poser d'ailleurs non
et puis et puis la ville de saint
barthélemy j'en ai suffisamment parc des
princes en pleine présidentielle mais
quand même
effectivement la sortie du royaume uni
va par ailleurs posé des problèmes
énormes en matière de programmation
budgétaire et vous le savez et rien
n'est réglé et il est donc on va de
toute façon vers un feu d'artifice final
comme l'avait dit d'ailleurs le prix
nobel d'économie quel comment
s'appelle-t-il de près bref vous voyez
qu'il y avait dix derniers américain qui
avait dit ce sont les noms paul krugman
ce sont ceux qui sortiront les premiers
de l'union européenne et de l'euro qui
s'en sortiront le mieux ce qui est
possible d'ailleurs je dis que c'est
possible
parfois ils peuvent très bien avoir une
politique budgétaire voire même de
dévaluations monétaires de la livre qui
va leur permettre effectivement de
donner l'illusion que dans les premiers
mois de leur indépendance réelle mais
que ses discours vous voyez que
l'apocalypse que vous avez péché pas
vous personnellement je trouve que le
discours change déjà parce que comme
l'apocalypse tant espéré par les drop is
n'arrive pas et que c'est les chiffres
sont plutôt vous l'avez rappelé
meilleure que chez nous voilà il faut
essayer de réadapter le discours juste
sur moi je pense que c'est même plus qu
une construction idéologique on est
arrivé au stade une religion moi j'ai vu
des gens chez les européistes hier qui
était presque en pleurs on avait
l'impression d'avoir toucher au sacré
l'europe il ya des grands prêtres qui
sont là pour définir une doxa qui
répètent des prières et qui sont
capables de vous excommunié si vous
n'êtes pas dans la doxa et c'est
vraiment une religion et quand on touche
à une religion pour certains qui sont
vraiment dans une foi sincère une
croyance mais on peut pas mettre le
problème c'est qu'on peut pas être le
destin des peuples dans une croyant même
pas l'aider parce que c'est trop
dangereux
willis parce que le oui le français
n'ont joué que moi il s'est heureusement
sur la dedans et d'ailleurs il a plutôt
voté contre
quand on lui a demandé rarement son avis
mais ça n'a pas été respectée mais les
élites françaises pour beaucoup sont
dans cette espèce de phénomènes
religieux qui est très dangereux parce
qu'on ne joue pas aux dés le destin d'un
pays tout entier or c'est ce qu'ils font
pas ce qu'ils veulent croire au lieu de
regarder la réalité
je réponds juste ce qu'il faut quand
même épuisés ce problème commercial vous
dit quand on est petit on perd les à
compeyre ces négociations commerciales
c'est faux bond on perd quand on n'est
pas content
de ses intérêts ce qui est le cas de
l'europe puisque c'est un nombre
considérable de pays qui ont des
intérêts contradictoires
la suisse négocie ces accords
commerciaux c'est beaucoup plus petit
que le royaume uni elle les gagne la
suisse a même des barrières commerciales
parme sur les produits agricoles plus
élevé que l'union européenne elle est
capable négocié ces accords commerciaux
parce qu'elle sait ce qu'elle veut
le canada ces grands sur une carte mais
le canada avec ça n'est que 35 millions
d'habitants ça n'est que 60% du pib de
la france
il a négocié comme un grand son accord
c'est ah le fameux traité c'est à avec
la grande union européenne et de la part
des observateurs
mais selon les observateurs honnêtes on
dit que le canada a gagné cette
négociation commerciale face à l'union
européenne et ses 500 millions
d'habitants voyez donc c'est pas eux
c'est pas big is beautiful
et c'est simplement est ce qu'un pays
est conscient de ses intérêts ou pas et
c'est vrai en tous domaines commerce et
autres et on est confiant ses intérêts
mais qu'on a ça s'ouvre va pas perdre
deux matches et on va toujours continuer
à commercer entre nous puisque les ça
c'est vous qui le ça c'est vous qui
l'avez il va y avoir le rôle mairie de
négociations ça dépend de nous avoir
savoir à l'issue de ce désaccord
on ne le saura même en juillet au soir
qu'est ce qui va se passer parce que si
ils veulent pas toucher le dumping si
ils ne veulent pas s'il le faut battre
dumping si ils maintiennent les règles
il prend d'abord accès au marché unique
mais s'ils ne le font pas le marché
unique va se fermer les 47 pour ça c'est
pas comme ça que les 47% de deux de
leurs exportations vers l'union
européenne si vous voulez voir
la taurine du royaume et deux
européennes un divorce après 47 ans de
vie commune et maintenant on en parle
dans quelques minutes à tout de suite
[Musique]
cet accord c'est un accord politique
ça va bien au delà d'une simple guerre
commerciale
il est clair que la chine avait quand
même beaucoup plus à perdre que les
états unis je suis pas convaincu tout de
même que le jeu ne soit pas plus
équilibré qu'il n'y paraît
vous avez un certain nombre de secteurs
d'activité aux états unis qui ont été
lourdement impactés s'aperçoit qu'ils
sont en train de perdre leur statut de
superpuissance et unique superpuissance
en la chine est un pays qui peut
beaucoup plus rapidement que n'importe
quel autre pays du monde se passer des
états unis et entraîné avec elle en plus
incertain d'autres pays européens que
c'est aujourd'hui la chine qui remet en
cause l'hégémonie américaine
[Musique]
à
et l'actualité c'est évidemment le
corona virus là aussi c'est un peu un
effet de la mondialisation
ton ami quand même plus d'un mois avant
que l'information remonte de ou ham
jusqu'à pékin dire que les premiers cas
du coronavirus remonte au mois de
novembre dans les effets économiques
commencent à se faire sentir et ils vont
se faire sortir notamment en france vous
et touristes mais il ya eu quand même
des mesures très autoritaire du
président bien sûr mais pour pouvoir
stopper la plantation et il n'y a que
des mesures autoritaires qui peut être
est ce qu a pas un message là en
direction de trump c'est que c'est
constant chez les chinois depuis
toujours un
c'est nous avons réussi en 30 ans à nous
développer à un niveau où rémy 200 ans à
le faire alors venez pas nous donner des
leçons alors là escapade là aussi une
autre leçon c'est que la mondialisation
dont on a dit que pis que pendre
on y va on n'est pas très bien outillé
c'est qu'aujourd'hui quand une épidémie
vient de chine
bah elle se répand dans le monde entier
[Musique]
pauli prague la suite avec nos
contributeurs patrick mennucci florian
philippot et nos invités françois foulée
mathis spécialiste de l'union européenne
et françois asselineau président de
l'upm le royaume uni qui est donc resté
quarante sept ans au sein de l'union
européenne avec toujours un pied dedans
un pied dehors pourquoi la
grande-bretagne n'at-elle jamais adhérer
à l'espace schengen et à la monnaie
unique françois poule et mathis la
grande bretagne n'a jamais adhéré
totalement au projet européen projet
police naturel en grande bretagne
n'était intéressé que par les échanges
et époux vis-à-vis de l'échec de la e et
le lc 10 elle est obligée effectivement
se tourner vers l'union européenne qui à
l'époque était la communauté économique
européenne
donc c'était par pragmatisme elle n'a
jamais été partie prenante d'un projet
politique d'intégration ça c'est
important le savoir n'empêche qu'en 1973
je m'en souviens très bien avec edward
heath lorsqu'ils ont signé l'adhésion
les anglais avaient un grand soupir de
soulagement qu'ils ont confirmé que ce
choix d'ailleurs lancé c'était aussi la
paix des nations non c'était aussi
c'était encore très présent mais surtout
parce que effectivement il était dans
une situation économique déplorable et
il avait besoin d'une union européenne
qui les a permis de relever en gardant
il faut bien dire que l'ensemble des
pays européens ont accepté toutes les
demandes britanniques ont accepté toutes
les exceptions britannique
c'est un cas unique et donc ils sont
quand même parti alors c'est que ces
deux mots négocier un événement
historique que vous devez connaître
aussi c'est le fameux discours de
churchill à zurich
lorsqu'il a dit mais l'aimions
européenne c'est très très important il
faut que les pays d'europe se réunissent
mais nous ne faut pas parler du plaisir
mais nous n'en ferons pas partie ça
toujours été dans l'option planning mais
pour eux pour churchill dont boris
johnson souhaite de prendre l'exemple la
tendance d'une union politique
européenne était fondamental est là on
va écouter margaret thatcher et sa
fameuse phrase je veux prendre mon
argent écoutez c'est en anglais n'ont
aucune excuse asking for money back
voilà la fameuse sera de margaret
thatcher est ce que boris johnson
finalement à terminer le travail
margaret thatcher en fait oui je crois
qu une certaine façon oui je pense qu'il
a abouti à une certaine logique
le laisse britannique vous avez on a
payé traditionnelle du wait en see
attendre et voir les awatib ils ont
attendu les racines sont vus c'est un
désastre
donc ils repartent très pragmatiquement
et ce qui est très important mal on a
reçu dans d'effectivement patrick
mennucci rappelait qui hier on a fait
une grande une grande fête une grande
fête avec et encore une fois il y avait
des représentants venant de droite et de
gauche et nous on a reçu des messages
venant de parlementaires de ministre
britannique pour le break cif et ce qui
était vraiment le fil directeur des
quatorze message que nous avons reçu
c'était qu'ils un système tous d'abord
et avant tout sur les questions de
liberté de démocratie c'est pour ça
qu'ils veulent c'est pas des questions
d'abord commercial d'abord c'est d'abord
un peuple qui retrouve sa liberté et sa
démocratie c'est de ça qu'il s'agit
fondamentalement comment voulez-vous que
on parlait de nlhe et et tristesse
buisson rouler gilet jaune
il est où le 64e week-end de gilet jaune
il est au royaume uni où il est en
france où est ce que l'on voit des
manifestants qui sont éborgné auquel on
arrache les mains au royaume uni ou en
france c'est ça la vérité ou est ce
qu'on a ces manifestations est pourquoi
les gilet jaune manifeste-t-il pourquoi
et bien pour le pouvoir
ils manifestent pour le pouvoir d'achat
pour la protection des oeuvres tout ça
c'est la faute de l'europe
oui la protection des droits sociaux
dans la démolition du droit du dd des
services publics
la démolition des retraites par
répartition tout ça est exigée par la
commission européenne par le rapport des
grandes orientations des politiques
économiques c'est la vérité vous pouvez
dire que vous pouvez présenter mais
s'est avéré ont fait danser les plus
écoutées aller au royaume uni et mesurer
la situation économique social et le
bien-être et le mode de vie des
britanniques est revenu en france et 10
points ou est-ce qu'on est le plus
triste sur les cellules je vous ai déjà
dit de sept dépôts précédent vous portez
la responsabilité de dédouaner le
gouvernement français samedi ternes
allemande de ses responsabilités nous
avaient colonisé la mairie actuelle
chaque fois que quelque chose cloche
dans ce pays chaque fois que quelque
chose ne va pas chaque fois qu'il ya une
manifestation vous faites référence au
gilet jaune à face à laura réseau c'est
la faute à londres et je voudrais vous
démontrer je voudrais vous démontrez que
vous avez qu à force
non je les dis aussi à françois fillon
parce que vous êtes les mêmes tous les
deux sur cette question fois sur cette
question vous êtes mêmes c'est pas vous
allez le broc mais on n en avait
peut-être jamais jusqu'à mélenchon que
ce soit je l'estimé beaucoup et vous
croyez que mélenchon et mon gourou quoi
voilà c'est pas du tout ces personnes
c'est moi c'est au coeur social est non
ici je me suis fier moi même avant dans
la réflexion s'il voulait et je pense
que vous aussi des donc la question vous
faites depuis fort longtemps l'un et
l'autre dans le jeu répond tous les deux
à la fois vous prenez chaque fois que
quelque chose ne va pas dans ce pays
vous leur envoyez à l'europe et je la
conseille quatre jours est terminée je
sais pas la parole au frigo est la
conséquence de cette attitude c'est que
vous dédouaner les dirigeants quels
qu'ils soient pour nous dédouaner mac os
ou parade avant vous des douaniers
valser et olam
oui oui vous l'aidez doit composer avec
la seule chose que vous le reprocher
c'est d'être dans le système européen et
non pas de la politique alors que ce
n'est pas une attitude oppose a gelé des
douanes d'autant moins que nous avons
lancé l'upm a lancé depuis plus d'un an
un dossier pour appeler les députés les
sénateurs a lancé la procédure de
destitution de maquereau qui procèdent à
des violations continuelles de la
constitution mais attendez vous
reconnaissez moi ça va faire des
reconnaissances pas quelque chose change
était candidat à l'élection
présidentielle
oh je me suis fait connaître parce que
je citais les articles des traités qui
expliquait les politiques c'est vrai ou
c'est pas vrai c'est donc ce n'est pas
des attaques du que c'est pas du café du
commerce que l'on dit c'était des
attaques n'étaient pas des attaques en
laye c'était jeudi expliqué aux français
je continue d'expliquer aux français
l'origine des problèmes
les violences policières aux quelque
chose c'est mon coup de coeur l'europe
se débat il n'y a pas de dédouanement
certainement pas parce que macro et
avant hollande et avant sarkozy et
d'autres sont adhère à tout cela et
n'écoute pas les français quand il
s'exprime sur la question européenne
comme on l'a fait par référendum très
clairement en 2005 ou ne posent pas la
question français qu'est ce qui
empêcherait emmanuel macron de faire le
même référendum parce qu'il connaît le
résultat il a dit lui-même à la bbc il
sait qu'on voterait dans après une
campagne après un débat comme les
britanniques
donc on les dédouane en rien en rien moi
je les porte comme très responsable en
revanche vous je vous accuse de ne pas
faire la pédagogie nécessaire et
d'expliquer aux français que les mesures
sur l'assurance chômage les retraites en
ce moment la libéralisation du rail qui
était un grand combat non la
libéralisation du rail et moi j'étais
dans les manifs françois trillo je crois
aussi
et plein d'autres il ya un an et demi où
il ya deux ans maintenant
c'était vous le savez très bien des
paquets ferroviaires des directives
européennes qui ont commencé en 91 et
progressivement on a démantelé ce
service public
la réforme des retraites elle vient pas
de nulle part non plus effectivement
quand on lit les recommandations de la
commission antenne depuis des années on
retrouve 7e mondial y à l'afp yvonne
on laisse il ya 1 heure là sont investis
que l'état rien est à cran et quand on
me dit à chaque fois vous non mais mais
je voudrais revenir au sujet fondamental
c'est pour natal juste un mot on a dit
pourquoi les britanniques n'ont pas
choisi vous avez posé la question
l'euro et schengen d'abord deux raison
de plus pour nous d'en sortir de chez
nous à l'euro en subit euro et schengen
et vous avez donné la réponse c'est un
peu pragmatique
donc il a commis là il aperçu que ces
politiques là celle de schengen et celle
de l'euro lui retirait de la liberté de
la marge de manoeuvre aussi bien sur la
question sécuritaire et migratoire d'un
côté que sur les questions économiques
et politiques puisque la monnaie c'est
très politique de l'autre et donc il a
choisi de conserver l son indépendance
là dessus ils ont eu raison
ils se sont rendu compte que ce n'était
pas suffisant les prisons division et
ils ont décidé finalement de quitter
l'union européenne c'est par pragmatisme
nous n'agissons pas à pragmatique c'est
pas nous nos dirigeants ils agissent par
idéologie et c'est absolument
catastrophique parce que cette idéologie
nous mène à faire des choix qui ne sont
pas connectés à nos intérêts à la
réalité que nous vivons ça qu'on soit
déroulé raison les véritables raisons
circuler mon vous éviter les débats sur
l'euro à l'époque ils vous expliquent
l'intérêt de garder la livre sterling
ils ont toujours été extrêmement heureux
de ne pas être entré dans cette aventure
catastrophique de l'euro est pour rien
au monde même quand il est temps dans
l'union européenne et ne voulait
rejoindre la zone euro mettez moi de
dire ça n'est pas ça qui a fait basculer
l'opinion britannique l'opinion
britannique à la bascule est sur une
toute autre question qui n'a rien à voir
c'est la crainte de l'immigration l'ont
maîtrisé ce succès symbolique et est là
c'est qu'il ya des enfants il est 5ème
journée c'est ça qui a basculé et donc
ne dit pas que c'est pour les régions et
que de percer j'avais fait beaucoup
suivi la campagne de 2016 c'était vrai
que la question migratoire a été dans la
campagne mais ça n'est pas vrai que
c'est le point principal la caisse que
le point trafic dans les dents les
milices et la liberté c'est la liberté
la démocratie on sait le poids de ce
fait ça ce que dit il
crainte de la mondialisation également
qui a été évoquée alors avec un
ultralibéral comment est ce qu'il va
pouvoir marcher direct parce que disait
monsieur philippot l'europe a été
libérale est elle cette discipline ou
n'a pas vu un peu les effets de celui
rallye c'est un petit peu outrancier qui
a eu des effets absolument déplorable
sur l'ensemble des opinions européennes
et ils n'ont pas compris que le monde
avait changé et que les gens avaient
besoin de plus de solidarité plus de
prise en compte ces c'est ça qui a joué
dans beaucoup d'opinions de plusieurs
pays européens jeu ce défi de l'europe
parce que l'europe est allé vers trop de
libéralisme
aujourd'hui elle quand elle a compris
qu'il fallait revenir à vivre mais
comment concrètement le fait d'aller
d'abord c'est quoi leur au contraire
c'est quoi leur l'europe c'est une
coalition que me disait jean monnet
d'état nation d'accord il considère que
sur un certain nombre de sujets ils ont
tout intérêt à mettre leurs actions
encore là plutôt qu'agir séparément pour
être beaucoup plus efficace concrètement
concrètement ça veut dire qu'il ya 27
états le périmètre d'ailleurs personne
n'a choisi on n'a jamais demandé aux
français s'ils étaient d'accord pour que
les slovènes et les tonfas partie de ces
états on a 27 et a maintenant puisqu'on
a perdu 1 et à 27 et à peut-être bientôt
29 avec l'entrée de la macédoine du nord
et de l'albanie qui sont les pays de
tous les trafics prostitution trafic de
drogue
les mafias qui vont entrer ils ont lu
robert lacroix était isolé et vous avez
vu que c'est le département d'état
américain qui fait qu'à envoyer un de
ses émissaires pour taper du poing sur
la table pour faire entrer ces deux
états et où ça ils vont tenter à prendre
selon réfugiés non mais vous savez très
bien que macron va passer sous la table
comme d'habitude est donc pertinent mais
vous allez voir c'est d'ailleurs il a
commencé déjà à réagir machine arrière
comment voulez vous qu'un périmètre
factice qu'il ne correspond donc les
français ça descendait dans la rue
demandez aux français quelles sont les
26 autres états membres de l'union
européenne ils savent pas comment voulez
vous qu'un étage pour y être c'est pour
des moins jeunes c'est messi renoncé à
fixer
croyez-le ou non non non non c'est parce
qu'ils constituent c'est par ses
divisions vision du peuple qui veut
aller c'est un numéro d'acteur vous
savez très bien que les alouettes au bo
vous savez très bien que les mamans
c'est le test même s'il est apte
les 26 autres les noms si j'avais me
dire je ne sers pas permis d sinon les
26 autres états ont légitimement des
intérêts nationaux divergents et vous
savez que par l'article 48 du traité de
l'union européenne il faut l'unanimité
des états membres pour changer une
politique ça veut dire que la politique
ultralibérale
on ne peut pas la changer puisque par
exemple on voudrait mettre une taxe
tobin sur les transactions financières
le luxembourg malte les pays bas une
grande partie des pdc te dirai non c'est
impossible
et tout est comme ça tout est bloqué
alors systématiquement je fais une
avance sur la grande bretagne puisqu'il
est question du brésil toujours d'une
solution à d'autres débats sur l'europe
évidemment elle est la grande bretagne a
des atouts néanmoins c'est la cinquième
économie mondiale une puissance
nucléaire premières armes et d'europe
avec la france un siège au conseil de
sécurité membre de l'otan et membre du
commonwealth avec tous ses atouts
françois poulet mathis finalement la
grande bretagne va pouvoir négocier tout
seul avec elle est allée en afrique
récemment pour pouvoir négocier des
désaccords commerciaux
sauf que le commonwealth c'est ça existe
toujours mais formellement la véritable
puissance de la bretagne est déjà acquis
au sein de l'union européenne
ça c'est la réalité à tel point qu'elle
a supprimé fin est là abandonné un peu
de toutes les ambitions qu'il avait avec
la haye le et c'est au sein de l'union
européenne
c'est parce que l'union européenne a
délégué son potentiel de commercial avec
l'extérieur
en mettant une voix unique qui n'ont pas
une voix de chacun des états européens
parce qu'il ya une voie et sur ce plan à
l'europe et fédérale puisqu'elle négocié
en ont au nom de leurs enfants une
quarantaine de sexe avait dix ans signé
avec simplement que la grande bretagne
demain lorsqu'elle va re des gossip à
peu près 6
sans traités commerciaux avec les
différents pays avec lesquels l'union
européenne était en relation
elle va devoir tout renégocier mais dans
quelles conditions quand l'animal
jonathan ne met pas du tout les mêmes
patients j'ai promis le siège de l'apc
passagers s'est uni à jose états-unis
l'angleterre les etats-unis il ya un
accord c'est le royaume et sympathie et
malia la france est un petit pays
dans son délire que j'ai envie de dire
une chose là dessus vous nous dites et
il faut et le son avenir où sont
présents je ne sais pas et dans l'europe
bon le monde ça vous a pas échappé est
beaucoup plus vaste que le simple
continent européen et c'est encore
beaucoup plus vrai aujourd'hui que ça ne
l'était en 1957 puisqu'on a eu des
puissances émergentes considérable en
asie en amérique en amérique du sud est
maintenant de plus en plus même en
afrique qui sont là donc c'est plutôt
une chance de se ré ouvrir sur le monde
moi je pense que l'autre grand problème
de ceux de cette union européenne ces
cas nous enferme en permanence sur on a
le nez sur bruxelles et berlin toute la
journée quoi or le monde je suis désolé
en 2020 et dans les années qui elle se
résume pas du tout à bruxelles et berlin
il faut aller voir ce qui se passe en
asie en afrique en amérique du sud en
amérique du nord etc
il faut aller à la conquête du monde
sait ce qu'ils vont pouvoir faire vous
nous dites ils vont pas réussi à
négocier des accords commerciaux mais
pourquoi donc
pourquoi l'avoir lu par les mêmes
conditions mais pas la belgique mais
tant mieux pour eux parce que vous
trouvez que l'union européenne la
commission a bien négocié les accords
commerciaux que nos agriculteurs nos
éleveurs sont protégés par ces accords
mais c'est une catastrophe pour les
livres à la concurrence déloyale
brésilienne canadiennes américaines et
souvent câble a sonné au livre au boeuf
aux hormones vous avez lu ces articles
cette semaine qu'ils aient finalement il
va y avoir dans les assiettes française
du poulet chloré américain et du boeuf
aux hormones canadien dans les assiettes
britannique non dans l'ancien
touché des tic le sommet réseaux sociaux
de ces traités épouvantable c'est pas
eux qui sont dans une idéologie qui
n'est pas celle de celle de nos intérêts
et l'intérêt notamment de noël va nous a
gagné 4 estime pas la première fois que
sur les réseaux sociaux ou des fans des
thèses
vaguement de conspirationnistes du
poulet mais là je veux dire sur la
question la question sur la question non
la question du rapport avec les
amériques et moi j'en donnais tout va
bien se passer avec les états unis
je regarde je me touré joueur les trois
derniers mois c'est quoi les désaccords
dans la grande bretagne et les etats
unis
des détails premier désaccord sur le
nucléaire iranien
mais oui ça à voir mais bien sûr
commerce à côté premier désaccord sur le
nikkei nucléaires iraniennes 2e d accord
sur le retrait des forces américaines
dans le nord de la syrie
troisième des accords très précisément
annoncée par boris johnson
d accord sur le nom sur soliva ni sur
ses dires sur le drone qui frappe le sol
et manie d'eau là on a trois
ça m'arrive à voir mais c'est à dire à
des relations internationales les radars
les mêmes et vous vous pensez que les
intérêts américains et britanniques vont
fonctionner non moi je vous dis adieu
les états unis vont essayer vont essayer
de dominer la grande bretagne et de ce
point de vue et de ce point de vue
monsieur asselineau c'est pas tout est
devenu l'accueil du bien cette agression
du gard de femmes parlent pas impuni a
maintenu sa taxe est aussi la femme la
fed à retirer à la sous pression
américaine et de surprises vous mettez à
2 contre dreux s'est arrêtée
non mais je veux dire dans le langage me
suis pas fier de venir mais je veux dire
laissez moi parler baleine deux bons
mois ce qui me paraît important ce que
je veux dire que je rigole mais j'en ai
bien quelque chose de positif sur la
grande bretagne est ce que je cours je
dirais ajouté je crois par exemple que
le traité de lancaster house qui ne le
traitez qui a été fait en 2 min sur les
questions militaires
il faut dire aux français aussi que ces
choses ne sont pas mises en cause qui
est important quand même de préciser moi
je prends beaucoup à la question
militaire à l'importance de la question
militaire dans les relations
internationales
on a là un traité qui solide il faut le
réaffirmer c'est pas être possible du
tout c'est un très bon quart d'heure on
a été alliée dans les deux guerres il
n'y avait pas d' europe
bon voilà donc ça c'est extrêmement
important et je pense que le problème du
lien entre la grande bretagne et les usa
évidemment vous allez avoir de la part
des états unis la volonté d'affaiblir
l'accord stratégique entre la france
cela je parle pas de de l'europe entre
la france et la grande bretagne vous
verrez comment donald trump ou d'autres
this l'issue du succès d'euro forme
pression pour affaiblir le rôle
stratégique de la phrase dans l'accord
avec la grande bretagne
alors je pèse pas que vous peut-être
denis avez vous pas pensé mais c'est une
question vous avez réagi tout nous on
est sans effet et dont vous êtes
toujours sur nos mains basses vasella de
là quelques jours vous avez toujours été
devant lui vous êtes dans quelques jours
deux fois
vous utilisez la grande bretagne doit
avoir une victoire politique
mais ce n'est pas si c'est la démentir
florian philippot le poulet chloré on
n'a pas été introduit en france il est
interdit les mêmes les américains ont
essayé mais ça n'entre pas sur le
territoire français je vais préciser
après allez-y la corse et a donc je
parle du canada ne il ya une enquête
notamment de rtl vous retrouverez sur
rtl.fr
retrouvez en direct c'est une personne
qui vous le dit prévoyez dans la
communication du gouvernement français
une protection sanitaire maximale or l'
enquête a démontré qu'un certain nombre
de produits y compris ses produits la
rentrée toujours sur le territoire
français ou entrer davantage sur le
territoire français qu'auparavant voilà
ce que j'ai dit ces accords commerciaux
ne font pas bon qu'on soit clair non
seulement pour nos 13 mai c'est bon mais
c'est très peu mangé du poulet chloré en
soit on peut manger alors que la marque
a dit tout le monde parce que je suis
pas joué est ce que vous payez caler
quelle est la réalité de sa belle
malheureusement vous êtes en train de
découvrir les joies du libre échange
voilà exactement comment on les achète
wilson c'est ben c'est pareil moi c'est
ça justement pour les il faudrait quand
même et je vais encore me faire
houspiller mais elle reprendre un peu de
hauteur de vue
pourquoi et oui bah oui oui pourquoi est
ce qu'il est non comme quoi des accords
commerciaux vont se passer finalement
bien parce qu'il ya un intérêt des parts
et d'autres
ce qu'il se passe bien la france et la
32 milliards de ventes à lui octroyer
aux munichois cannes et de produits elle
en a pas de vins c'est à dire que nous
dégageons 12 milliards d'euros
d'excédent commercial
c'est notre premier excédent commercial
ça veut dire que si la france
comme je l'avais entendu nous disait il
faut absolument punir le royaume uni
vous habitez ce qu'a dit c'est jusqu'à
10 boris johnson
il a dit dans ce cas là on va taxer le
champagne et ça et on achètera du
champagne et du vin sec d'australie
exactement d afrique du sud et puis
quelque chose qu'il faut savoir c'est
que le commerce extérieur pas seulement
entre le royaume uni et la france n'a
aussi entre le royaume uni et
l'allemagne par exemple c'est du
commerce intra entreprise ce sont des
pièces détachées automobiles pour
l'entreprise les gîtes
les entreprises allemands donc tous les
grand conglomérat allemand par exemple
ou français vont vouloir négocier et
obtenir rapidement une situation qui
soit conforme à l'intérêt de tous vous
avez qu à 3800 entreprises françaises
comptent investir au royaume uni qui
font 120 milliards d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires c'est l'investissement direct
à l'étranger alors qu'il n'ya que 1200
entreprises britanniques qui sont
présentes en france l'intérêt de la
france et la france à pau ou plus
intérêt à maintenir de très bonnes
relations avec le royaume uni que
l'inversé c'est pour ça que ça va bien
se passer
je montre t elle c'est à un an après la
france laisse encore entrer des produits
canadiens toxiques
voilà la france s'était promis de ne pas
laisser entrer n'importe quoi c'est raté
pour laisse la nation c'est rtl qui dit
c'est pas moi voilà c'est simplificateur
direct merci beaucoup c'est l'heure du
coup de gueule à présent
[Musique]
et votre coup de gueule florian
philippot ce sont les affrontements
encore avec les policiers lors de la
manifestation de compter six mois j'ai
été sais pas c'était pas la première
fois ça s'est produit à quelques
semaines je suis extrêmement choqué et
attristé de voir des scènes en france
maintenant ou régulièrement des pompiers
et des policiers se battent dans la rue
les pompiers aussi sont tabassés par
certains policiers dans les
manifestations de pompiers qui sont
quand même légitime et évidemment les
pompiers sont pas les seuls à être
tabassés puisque à des dérives terrible
contre françoise kg en parlais tout à
l'heure contre certains manifestants et
gilet jaune depuis maintenant plus d'un
an
mais quand ça touche aux pompiers je
crois que c'est encore plus choquant
pour la population française parce que
ce sont quand même des gens qui sont des
héros que nous respectons qui risquent
leur vie pour la m et en plus souvent
bénévoles en tout cas volontaire mais il
se trouve que je pense que ça vient pas
de nulle part je pense que nous sommes
dans une société où le pouvoir manque de
plus en plus de légitimité parce qu'il
n'a plus d'assise démocratique réelle et
c'est complètement lié à notre débat
européen et donc il tient un bar à force
par la menace par l'intimidation par
l'exemple pour que pas trop de monde
aille dans la rue et ça nous ça nous
amène à cela qu'un ministre de
l'intérieur laisse d un corps d'état
comme les policiers s'affrontent avec un
autre corps comme les pompiers je trouve
ça terrible pour la république et pour
la france et pour vous patrick mennucci
un coup de gueule également contre le
maire de carry-le-rouet je me trouve je
trouve vraiment que l'attitude de jean
montagnac qui est le maire
les républiques et un ami très proche
jean claude gaudin d'avoir alors il a
reculé depuis 1 mais d'avoir été aussi
violent à l'égard de chantier
malheureusement ce dans une situation
terrible pro et qui vont devoir rester
cloîtrés pendant quinze jours dans un
centre de vacances
oui s'il fait soleil parce qu'on est
dans une période et je crois que ça doit
pas amusé beaucoup de gens je trouve que
vraiment la façon dont il a réagi à
l'égard de ses 400 x 2 et qui se nomme
dans l'inquiétude dans la souffrance
mais voilà et de leur famille est
vraiment pas au niveau est bon comme je
voulais le dire parce que je trouve
vraiment que i besoin de solidarité dans
cette affaire là où c'est pas de comment
ça se passe et on sait pas combien de
nos compatriotes vont subir cette
maladie et je crois que vous ferez mieux
de se serrer les coudes plutôt que
d'avoir ce genre d'attitude pas de ne
pas être trop alarmiste non plus bien
sûr merci beaucoup patrick mennucci
merci florian philippot pour votre
contribution à pôle it mag merci
françois poulet mathis et merci à vous
françois asselineau d'avoir répondu à
nos questions sur rt france c'est la
pince et la fin de polypes mag
restez avec nous
[Musique]
c'est quoi pour vous fils république
éthique écoutez c'est une république qui
se préoccupent de lutter contre la
corruption et contre la fraude fiscale
qui a conscience que c'est un enjeu
considérable
le coût de la corruption et est évalué à
pour la france chaque année à 120
milliards le coût de la fraude fiscale
entre 80 et 100 milliards chaque année
évidemment cet argent pourrait être
beaucoup mieux employé dans un lieu la
sphère pin up fillion la classe
politique rappelez-vous étaient sidérés
ne comprenait pas le problème lorsqu'il
faisait tous ça depuis des années chaque
année on nous avons nous découvrons des
pratiques